It's now time for Nut Chuggers.
Nut Chuggers.
There is a growing health crisis
in our parks,
our woods,
and even our backyards.
I'm talking about fat squirrels.
Look at him!
Like this guy from Imgur user
theInventorArtist.
Uh, it's time to lay off
the acorn-dogs, chubster.
Now, honestly...
Did you get a vision
of a tiny little bun
-with little nuts in it?
-CUMMINGS: Yes, yes.
(chewing sounds)
-That's so hot! -"I eat
to cover my feelings up."
Uh, now, due to milder winters
caused by global warming,
there is an excess of nuts
and berries,
so these little guys
are just stuffing their faces
all year long.
Oh, they don't know
when to quit.
And the nature photographers
can't seem to get enough
of these BBSs.
Big, beautiful squirrels. Uh...
"Hey, you guys,
real squirrels have curves."
Uh...
But clearly these chubsters
don't know
what global warming is,
so, comedians,
I'm gonna show you
some squirrel fatties
and then you're gonna help them
explain to their wives
why they're packing
on the pounds, all right?
-First one, this little hairy
and homely guy. -(bell dings)
-Whitney Cummings.
-GUBLER: That's cute.
I'm sorry, honey. I just love
having nuts in my mouth.
All right, points.
Next one, hey,
help this chunky guy out.
-(bell dings) -Help this
chunky guy out. Nick Swardson.
Sorry, I wanted to be a squirrel
for Halloween.
Sincerely, Chris Christie.
Oh, (bleep). Points.
-Next up, uh, Nick.
-(bell dings)
I'm hotboxing, man.
It's hibernation.
All right, points.
Points.
Next up, this chipper mechanic.
-(bell dings)
-This chipper mechanic. Whitney.
If you don't like me
at my worst,
you don't deserve me at my best.
Yes. All right.
-Finally, this-this gluttonous
grey gobbler. -(bell dings)
Gray Gubler.
Perfect. Thank you.
I eat because I'm sad,
and I'm... and I'm sad
because I just ate
my entire (bleep) family.
Yeah, all right. Points.
Points to Matthew.